- I was like, I said, "Bra maybe you
"should be vegan, you know."
I'm not vegan but (laughs).
It felt good to be the
messenger of this documentary.
(chimes)
(whooshing)
Nah, I don't trust no one.
So what it is, I set
up Netflix for my mom.
'Cause my mom doesn't really
know how Netflix works.
I had the family account.
Had the family account (laughs).
So I had the family account, right?
I set it up for my mom
and it was my profile.
And my mom, she doesn't,
I tried to say to my mom,
to watch something, like, "Mom
you gotta check out things
"like 'Power', 'Stranger
Things', all these like,
"'Breaking Bad.'"
But my mom will just watch
some random Steven Seagal.
- Hiyah
- Is it Seagal, Steven
Seagal is that his name?
The guy who puts everyone in
head locks with the pony tail.
His name is Steven Seagal.
He's rubbish man (laughs).
In the 90's he was good but all he does
is put people in head locks.
And he never gets hit.
He never really takes a blow.
You know sometimes there's
always the struggle scene
with a knife and then like (groans).
I push on to you, you push on to me.
He never really takes
a hit, Steven Seagal.
But my mom just watches real,
like weird films like that.
I'm a bit annoyed because she
doesn't really take full use
of the the Netflix experience.
You know what I mean.
(trilling)
What do I watch on Netflix?
So I watch a lot of documentaries.
I like to be woke.
I like to just watch something
and then tell people stuff.
I watched "FOOD, INC.," which
is about the food industry
and stuff like that.
I was just telling people.
I was like...I said,
"Bra maybe you should be vegan, ya know."
I'm not vegan, but
(laughs) it felt good to
be the messenger of this documentary.
That's what I like about documentaries,
but I tell you one thing I do like.
I like, there's a show on
Netflix called "Blown,"
about glassing blowing.
Listen man, that program is,
yeah, it's the "Bake off"
of glass blowing basically.
And yeah it's good, it's good.
I like that program.
That's like a program that I know none
of my friends watch it.
So it's just like, "Hey bro have you seen
this program, 'Blown.'"
And they're like, "What?
"Is it about like the drug
industry and like drugs?"
And I went, "Nah it's
about glass blowing."
But yeah that's one of my...I like that.
But also, I tell you
what I like on Netflix.
You know when you look at
someone else's Netflix,
and you see what they watch.
I be judging people's Netflix man.
I'll see people's Netflix.
I'm like, "What? Benidorm?" (laughs)
"What? That's on there and
you watch that? Boo!" (laughs)
(trilling)
Do I watch other comedy on Netflix?
I do, I do watch a lot of specials.
You know I watch, obviously
the Chappelle specials.
I normally watch them when I'm traveling.
They're always quite
good when I'm traveling.
I guess when I'm at home,
I try to watch things
that are not comedy.
But what if I'm not on
the road and traveling
then you kinda like wanna do...
I guess for me it's almost
like research a little bit.
So, yeah, Chappelle's, Chris
Rock, um who was it, Bill Burr.
I seen a Bill Burr special, that was good.
(trilling)
It is because, I guess, Yeah
it's just a lot of countries.
And there sometimes countries, you just...
You're like, It's not even countries.
Just places in the world
that I've never been to
that are gonna have the chance
to experience this special.
And you never know who's
watching it where, ya know.
I think that's really
the cool thing about it.
Is that it's gonna come out
and the way that I consume entertainment
when I'm on Netflix.
And I'm like, "Ah, I'll
check out this thing
about glass blowing."
I don't know if the people
who made the program knew
that I'd be a fan of that program.
I think that's the cool thing about,
when you've got a special, is that,
there's gonna be somebody who's like me,
who's like, "Ah what's this,
oh okay I'll check this out."
And they actually like it and
they tell people about it.
Yeah it's quite a surreal moment.
Yeah I'm kinda looking
forward to when it comes out
and seeing people's reactions.
(trilling)
I like... "Die Hard" is
most probably up there.
Big fan of some of the Guy
Ritchie films like, "Snatch",
"lock stock."
Yeah I'd most probably go with "Die Hard."
The first one in the
tower, the Nakatomi Tower.
Yeah that's most probably up there.
It's just everything I like.
It's got bit of comedy,
bit of action, drama, action, so yeah.
Most probably up there.
(trilling)
My favorite TV show...
"Breaking Bad," yeah, yeah.
I discovered "Breaking Bad"
'cause some of my friends
was talking about it.
And I don't think I had ever
really watched the TV shows
at that point.
So I thought, "Okay I'll give this a go."
And my friends are doing that thing,
where they've already seen it
and they was like, "Oh wait
till you get to season four."
And I'm on season two.
So I was like, "Okay."
And then you get to season four
and it lives up to that expectation.
And I really followed it.
I remember when they brought
it back out on Netflix
and it was coming out.
I think it was kinda like, weekly,
that it was coming out,
if I can remember rightly.
And yet it was thing were you're like,
"Don't tell me what happens."
You have to not go on social media
but yeah that for me is most
probably my best TV series.